طوابير لا نهاية لها على الطريق إلى الاسكندرون،
صرخة مدينة مدمرة طلباً للمساعدة
استجابت لها أمة في حالة صدمة متحدة في
الألم، على الرغم من أن هؤلاء العقليين قادوا السيارة لأكثر
من ثماني ساعات وهم يحملون الحفاضات والماء
والخبز، كل ما يمكنهم فعله لمساعدة
الغرباء الذين يحتاجون إلى كل ما يمكنهم الحصول عليه من
الدمار.  في كل ركن من أركان المدينة
لم يسلم أي مبنى من غضب الطبيعة الأم،
لذلك حتى في هذا الجزء من المدينة حيث لا
تزال المباني قائمة، يمكنك أن ترى
أن هناك شقوقًا في جميع أنحاء هذه
المباني التي تعرضت للضرر لذا
سيتعين علينا السير عبرها  هنا
سريعًا جدًا، لا نعرف مدى
استقرار هذه الهياكل الآن
في ثوانٍ، الحياة المحطمة وسبل العيش
دمرت مدينة وترك أهلها
مكسورين أنا في حيرة من أمري
لا أعرف كيف أشعر بأن
الخادم لا معنى له كان هنا يبحث عنه
صديقي الوحيد المتبقي تحت
حطام هذا المبنى السكني لا يوجد رجال
إنقاذ محترفون هنا فقط
متطوعين يلقون مخططات أرضية
لبحثهم في التراب في
اليوم الأول كنت متفائلًا حقًا ولكن هذا
هو اليوم الرابع الذي
أخرج فيه من الأمل حتى
النهايات السعيدة هنا طغت عليها
الحزن الجماعي الذي عاد به بوراك من
منزله في لندن للعثور على أخته
وأقاربه الآخرين، إنها معجزة أنهم
اكتشفوا أنهم دفنوا تحت
الأنقاض لمدة 15 ساعة، أخبرنا أنني عاجز عن
الكلام
أنا  في حلم، حلم سيء للغاية،
سمعت أنك تعرف أن الكثير من
أصدقائنا يموتون هنا، والعديد من
الأقارب يموتون، لقد انهارت مشاعري كلها،
أنا أتنفس فقط في هذه
اللحظة
القريبة نجد سهيل يشرف
على مهمة البحث  هنا منذ
أيام وهو يحاول يائسًا
إخراج والديه، تساعد حكومتنا ولكن
هذا ليس كافيًا، لذلك نحن
نحاول إخراج شعبنا بمفردنا ونحتاج
إليك، نحتاج إلى كل من يمكنه أن
يأتي ويساعدنا،
لقد رأى ساق والدته تحت  الأنقاض
لا
أستطيع الوصول إليها،
إنها هناك أراها لكنني لست
متأكدًا من أنني أفهم أن والدتي ماتت،
أحاول الوصول إلى والدتي
مع كل ساعة تمر حيث يسمع الكثيرون
أن الثقل المؤلم ينتهي
مع الأمعاء-  الواقع المؤلم يغرق في
جيوفاني كراتشي. سي إن إن هي تركيا